there were a lot of conservatives right
now who here when we talk about the
Constitution and these abstract
philosophical ideas who say that's I
don't I don't care about things that are
floating in the sky I want tangible
results and I think there is a way to
bring these things together which is the
American way of life there is an
American way of life where all these
great philosophical ideas have actually
been embodied in real institutions and
real rights that we've all cherished for
a very long time that the left is trying
to destroy and I just think if
Republicans would get down to Brass tax
and say you know
this the stuff that's going on in our
streets it's just wrong we don't like it
it's not part of our political tradition
which comes from our ideas and the way
it's been enacted get back to that get
back to that America that we cherish and
love Trump did a very good job of of
putting it in really practical terms and
I just fear sometimes Republicans we're
too Pie in the Sky about it just give
people something to hold on to in this